[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم سلمى الجمل
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه
وتتفاعلوا اخرى في اليوم التاسع من
منافسات كاس العالم قطر 2022 هذه الصور
قبيله الشوط الثاني من مباراه البرتغال
والاوروغواي في نهايه الجوله الثانيه من
دوري المجموعات
ومن العاصمه الصوماليه مقديشو هذه الصور
بعد ساعات من اعلان اجهزه الامن الصوماليه
انتهاء العمليه التي شنتها حركات الشباب
المجاهدين على فندق قرب القصر الرئاسي
ودامت نحو يوما كامل
ومن الخرطوم نتبعه هذه الصور اثر اصدار
رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقاليه السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان قرارا بتجميد نشاط
النقابات والاتحادات المهنيه والاتحاد
العام لاصحاب العمل
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
وصفه مؤشرات على عمليه بريه وشيكه تركيا
تكثف قصفها لمواقع فصائل كرديه في الشمال
السوري بالطائرات الحربيه ومدافعها وزاره
واردوغان ينتقد معتبره دعم دول غربيه
لتنظيمات ارهابيه ويقول ان تركيا لن
تستاذن احدا لحمايه اراضيها
بعد اشتباكات لقرابه احدى وعشرين ساعه
انتهائه هجوم مسلحي حركه الشباب في فندق
قرب القصر الرئاسي بمقديشو السلطات
الامنيات تعلن مقتل المهاجمين كافه ورئيس
الصومالي يطالب المجتمع الدولي بدعم
حكومته في ما سماها الحرب على الارهاب
وصفه تحذيرات الاوكرانيه من حشد روسيا
سفنا حربيه في البحر الاسود
يحذر من تصعيد روسيا هجماتها على محطات
الطاقه ويدعو للاستعداد لشتاء قاس وقارس
في اوكرانيا والامين العام للنيترو يؤكد
من جديد ضروره الحيلوله دون انتصار بوتن
في الحرب والبنتاجون يدرسوا ارسال اسلحه
مداها 150 كم الى اوكرانيا
بعد احتجاجات في انحاء الصين رفضا للاغلاق
السلطات تشدد الاجراءات الامنيه وتخفف
قيودا فرضتها بسبب كرونا في مقاطعه شينجان
واشنطن وعواصمه غربيه على خط الازمه تطالب
بضمان حق الاحتجاج السلمي والامم المتحده
تطالب بجين باحترام معايير حقوق الانسان
الدوليه
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه نقشنا اعلان محطاتي تلفزيون
عالميه ان ان كاس العالم الحاليه قطر 2022
هي الاكثر متابعه في تاريخ اللعبه فقد
نهزت اعداد المتابعين لمباراه الولايات
المتحده وانجلترا على قناه فوكس 20
مليون شخص في بعض مراحلها وفي اوروبا عرفت
مباراه المانيا واسبانيا مساء الاحد
متابعه 17 مليون مشاهد لشركه زي دي اف في
الالمانيه على سبيل المثال والاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم ما هي اسباب
ارتفاع نسبه المشاهده القياسيه لكاس
العالم الحاليه ثلاثه وخمسون في المئه
اعاد الاسباب الى مستوى البطوله والمنافسه
وعذ- وعزا 28% الامر الى التغطيه
الاعلاميه بينما قالت 19% ان السبب هو
لقيته البطوله هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا
على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ارض الظاهر على
الشاشه
لقاءنا على المنصه الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
بعد الحصاد مباشره وتحديدا في الساعه
الثانيه وخمس دقائق بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
تتابعون الجوله الرياضيه اليوميه يوميات
المونديال التي ترصد بالخبر والتحليل
مباريات كاس العالم قطر 2002 و 2020
[موسيقى]
لن نستاذن احدا لحمايه اراضينا ولم يعد
مقبولا تقديم بعض الدول الغربيه الدعم
لتنظيمات الارهابيه هي الرساله الاحدث من
الرئيس التركيه رجب طيب اردوغان كان يتحدث
فيها عقب اجتماعيه لمجلس الوزراء تركي
تصدره التوغل البري المحتمل في شمال
السوري في الاسنان يتواصلوا القصف التركي
بالطائرات الحربيه ومدافع الهوزر لمواقعي
فصائل كرديه شماليه سوريا
تامين الحدود من خارج الحدود
لا ينشغل الجيش التركي كثيرا بالجزل حول
المدى الذي قد تذهب اليه عمليه المخلب
السيف بل ينظر في قصر مواقع ما تعرفه باسم
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه تلك التي يرى
الاتراك ابرز فصيل فيها امتدادا لحزب
العمال الكردستاني المصنف من قبل انقره
وواشنطن والاتحاد الاوروبي منظمه ارهابيه
فاننا نقبل المحاسبه من احد ايضا ليس
علينا ان نتسامح مع نفاق اولئك الذين
يدعمون التنظيمات الارهابيه من خلال تغيير
الاسماء وصل عملياتنا العسكريه حتى القضاء
على اخر عنصر من التنظمات الارهابيه
[موسيقى]
لا تخفي تركيا ان هدف عملياتها العسكريه
هو اقامه حزام امني على طول حدودها
الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الشرقيه مع كل من
سوريا والعراق نحو استكمال تلك الغايه
يركز الجيش التركي على محاور ثلاثه هي عين
العرب كوباني
ومنبج ويقول مسؤولون الاتراك ان الجيش لا
يحتاج سوى لايام قليله ليكون جاهزا لعمليه
توغل بري باتت حتميه في شمال سوريا في
مقابل ذلك تهدد ما تعرف بالاداره الذاتيه
لشمال وشرق سوريا برد قاسم اذا ما استمرت
الهجمات التركيه
كما تطالب الولايات المتحده وروسيا بتحديد
موقف واضح من تلك الهجمات
ودوليه توجه انتقادات للعمليه العسكريه
التركيه شماليه سوريه والعراق
موسكو وهي حليف دمشق الابرز لا تخفي وجود
خلافات مع انقره حول المساله لكنها تشير
الى وجود مستوى من التفاهم والاحترام
المتبادل يشكل اساسا لمناقشه مثل تلك
القضاء الصعبه هل المساله اصعب مع
الامريكيين المعروف دعمهم لوحدات حمايه
الشعب في سوريا
بانتظار اتضاح حجم العمليات العسكريه
التركيه ونطاقها الجغرافي تكتفي واشنطن
بالدعوه الى التهدئه
يرد الاتراك بان احدا لا يحق له اعتراضه
تحركاتهم العسكريه الراميه لحمايه امنهم
يقولون انهم مصممون على القضاء على
الارهاب في منابعه لكن دون تعريض المدنيين
او قوات التحالف الدولي للخطر
في المقابل قالت بيان العلي الرئيس
المشتركه لما يعرف بمكتب الدفاع في
الاداره ذاتيه لشمالي وشرق سوريا قالت ان
الرد سيكون قاسيا اذا استمرت الهجمات
التركيه وطلبت العلي الدولتين الضامتين
لوقف اطلاق النار الولايات المتحده وروسيا
بتحديد موقفا واضح من هذه الهجمات وباي ان
يتحمل المجتمع الدولي مسؤولياته تجاه
الاداره الذاتيه وما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه حسب قولها
دعوه الرئيس التركي الى وقفه ما سماها
لعبه حزب العمال الكردستاني والفصائل
الكرديه الاخرى تطرحوا علامات استفهام عن
علاقات الحزب مع حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطيه
الكردي في سوريا وذراعه العسكريه وحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه التي تشكل العمود
الفقري لما تعرفه بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه
نسيج هذه العلاقه في التقرير الثالث
[موسيقى]
سوريا والذين تستهدفهم انقر حاليا بضربات
جويه ومدفعيه وقد تتطور الى عمليه عسكريه
تسيطر على مناطق شمال شرقي سوريا ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وهي تنظيم اسس
عام 2015 يتكون من فصائل ابرازها وحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه ووحدات حمايه المراه
اضافه الى قوات حرس الخابور وقوات
الصناديد وفصائل الى اخرى لكنه وحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه وحدات حمايه المراه
وهما فصلان قوامهما مسلحون اكراد هما
الاكثر عرضا وتسريحا وتحكما بمراكز القرار
والقياده ضمن ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه كما انهما اقدم ظهورا ويشكلان
الذراع العسكريه بحزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي
المؤسس شمال شرق سوريا عام 2003 هذا الحزب
تصنفه التركي على انه الفرع السوري لحزب
العمال الكردستاني المعروف اختصارا
والمصنف تنظيم الارهابيا فيصاليا لدى
تركيا وواشنطن والاتحاد الاوروبي
القائد الحالي لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه مظلوم عبدي نشرت له صور في
وقت سابق تقول بشانها المصادر التركيه
الرسميه انها تظهر تبعيته ومعظم مقاتل
الفصائل الكرديه في سوريا لحزب العمال
الكردستاني الذي شكل نهايه السبعينيات
القرن الماضي ويتمركز قاده وكثير من
مقاتله في جبال قنديل الممتده عند الحدود
العراقيه الايرانيه التركيه مقاتل حزب
العمال الكردستاني
انتحاريه وتفجيرات داخل تركيا وفق
المسؤولين الاتراك في المقابل شن التركيه
عمليات بريه ضد مسلح التنظيم الكردي في
جبال قنديل وداخل اراضيها بهدف القضاء
عليه او الحد من نشاطه على اقل تقدير
انضموا علينا من اسطنبول الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي بورا بيرقدار ومن واشنطن الدكتور
اندرو تابلت المدير السابق لقسم سوريا في
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي والمستشاره
السابق للمبعوث الامريكي الخاص الى سوريا
مرحبا بكما سعيد برقدار هالفتره العمليه
العسكريه التركيه البريه امرا حتميا ام ان
هناك حيز للمناوره
ان يكون هنالك عمليه بريه تبدا بانه اذا
ما تذكرتهم قبل اسبوعين كان هنالك هجوم
ارهابي في قلب اسطنبول وبعد اسبوع فقط
تركيه قامت باطلاق عمليه جويه في العراق
وسوريا ضد وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
وايضا حزب العمال الكردستاني الذي حملته
المسؤوليه لهذه الهجمات ذلك الرئيس التركي
عده مرات تاكد على حقيقه ان تركيا
بامكانها في اي وقت تبدا ان تطلق هاجمات
وفي هذه الايام هنالك توقعات في
داخل تركيا واذا ما نظرنا ايضا الى الوضع
في الميدان هنالك تزايد وبنات القوات
العسكريه تركيه
لوجستيك عمليات ارسال لوجستيه الى المناطق
الحدوديه وايضا الموارد في اجزاء الشماليه
في مع شمال سوريا علمنا ان هنالك بعض
المعدات العسكريه موجوده في تلك المنطقه
بالتالي فان اي هجمه ضد الفصائل الارهابيه
في شمال سوريا هو امر محتمل والتوقع هو
نعم انه امر وشير
هل باستطاعته واشنطن ان تاخذ موقفا محددا
وواضحا من عمليه عسكريه تركيه بريه كما هو
مطالب منها ان كان من قبل همم ما تعرف
الاداره ذاتيه لقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
ومن قبل الطرف التركي
في موقف صعب للغايه هي متحالفه مع قوات
وحدات مكافحه وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
في شمالي سوريا وايضا هذه الوحدات هي عدوه
لتركيا لارتباطها بحزب العمال
اذا ما كانت قادره على القيام بشيء ما من
اجل ايقاف هذه العمليه لربما قد تكون
سمعنا به الان وكيف باستطاعت الواتساب
وما بين ايضا قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
وعلاقتها بها هذه العلاقه الامنيه التي
تشترك فيها في تلك المناطق الشماليه شرقي
سوريا
عليها ان تقوم بذلك عن طريق جهود
الدبلوماسيه مكاتفه كما حصل في عام 2019
من اجلي ان تدير ايضا ربما عمليات الدخول
عبر الحدود وان لا يكون هنالك ايذاء
للحلفاء في قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه جهدي
مثل هذا من قوه من عفوا من اداره لانها لا
تريد ان تضيء ليس هنالك رغبه في تغيير
الحالي
الى اداره
السياسيه التي تنجم عن قيامها بعمليه
عسكريه خاصه فيما يتعلق في علاقتها مع
حليفها واشنطن وايضا علاقتها مع اطراف
الروسي
انه سيكون هنالك ثمن سياسي غالي لتركيا
بسبب هذه العمليه لانه بدايه انفا ان
تركيا والولايات المتحده قام بتوقيعي
مذكره تفاهم في عام 2019 قبل ان عمليه
الربيع التي اطلقتها تركيا بالتالي
الولايات المتحده فقط وتركيا وافقت على
اتفاق مشابهه
على ان المجموعات الارهابيه يجب ان تكون
بعيده عن الحدود التركيه وقد اكد على حصول
لهذا الامر لكن هذا الامر لم يحصل بالتالي
تركيات تريد ان يكون
لديها ممر او منطقه امنه عازله لن يسمح
لهذه المجموعه الارهابيه بالمرور عبرها
بالتالي لم يتم تحقيق هذا الامر لتركيا
مؤخرا رايناه وكما في الهجوم الاخير فان
المجموعات الارهابيه ما تزالناشطه اذا ترك
تركيا
وايضا سيتم وقد تم اتوافق عليها من قبل
الاطراف بالاضافه الى ذلك فان تركيه تقدم
حجتها الى اتفاق حسب اتفاق اذنه مع سوريا
ولذي يسمح لتركيا بمطاردته الارهابيين في
داخل الاراضي السوريه
التاليه
ابيض عن البيت الابيض يقول بان تركيا
تتعرض بهجمات ارهابيه على حدودها وداخل
اراضيها وندعم حقها في الدفاع عن نفسها هل
تنظر تعليق على مثل هذا الحديث من قبل
البيت الابيض بانه الضوء اخضر لتركيا في
عمليتها البريه ام ماذا
افلام تركي
فان تركيه لا تبحث عن اي ضوء اخضر هذه
سياسه
مستمره منذ سنوات وخاصه بعد عام 2016
في دفاعها عن نفسها
اريد
ان تركيا لديها
تتعرض لتهديدا ارهابيه والسؤال هو هل ان
هذا الامر يضع محددات عما تستطيع تركيا
والى اي مدرسه يصل شكرا لك من واشنطن
اندرويد همم
المدير السابق لقسم سوريا في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي والمستشاره السابق
للمبعوث الامريكي الخاص الى سوريا وايضا
من اسطنبول الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
[موسيقى]
بعد معركه استمرت يوما كاملا تقريبا قالت
الشرطه الصوماليه ان القوات الامن اقتحمت
فندق في العاصمه مقديشو اليوم
حركه الشباب المجاهدين على الفندق
الهجوم طلبه الرئيس الصومالي حسن شيخ
محمود المجتمع الدولي بالوقوف الى جانبه
حكومه بلاده من اجل هزيمه وصفه بالارهاب
تلفزيون فندق في الراس الواقع على مقربه
من القصر الرئيسي في مقديشو عاقبه اقتحام
المسلحين من حركه شباب وتحصنهم داخلها
الصوره هي ذاتها بعد كل هجوم خسائر بشريه
واضرار ماديه جسيمه وفي اول تعليق له على
الحادث قال الرئيس الصومالي ان بلاده تخوض
حرب
هناك من يتفهم طبيعه حربنا ويقف الى
جانبنا وادعوا الاخرين ان يجلسوا ان اعمل
سويا في محاربه هذا العدو المشترك فهو لا
يهددنا فحسب وانما العالم اجمع لذا علينا
التعاون لهزيمه هذا العدو المشترك
الهجوم على فندق يقع في منطقه يفترض انها
محسنه امنيا قد يثير براي لمراقبين
تساؤلاتنا حول النجاح الاجراءات الامنيه
التي تتبعها قوات الامن الحكوميه بهدف
الحد من تهديدات حركه الشباب
ياتي هذا الهجوم بينما تشتد المواجهات بين
القوات الصوماليه ومقاتل حركه الشباب في
اكثر من مكان في ولايته شمال
حيث نجاحه القوات الحكوميه في انتزاع
السيطره على مناطق عده فيهما مواجهات اما
كانت الحكومه من تحقيق بعض الانجازات فان
التساؤلات كثيره تطرح عن جدوا مع التكرار
الهجمات التي تستهدف العاصمه مقر الحكومه
المركزيه هذا يعني ان الحركه تملك قدرات
عسكريه وماليه وامنيه كذلك وهي ايضا
الاشاره الى ان الغارات الجويه وحدها لا
تكفي ياتي في سياق رد الحركه على همم
الهجمات التي تعرض لها خلالها الشهور
الثلاثه الاخيره حيث فقدت مرادف
استراتيجيه وسط الصومال
وتعيش مقدشر التي لم تعرف الهدوء بعد خلال
العقود الاخيره على وقف معركه مفتوحه بين
الحكومه وحركه شباب هي اشبه ما تكون في
معركه كسر العظام عمر محمود الجزيره
مقديشا
عبد الرحمن سهل الباحث هو المحلل السياسي
سيد عبد الرحمن بماذا تفسر استطاعه حركه
الشباب المجاهدين الوصول الى مثل هذا
الفندق في قلب العاصمه مقديشو الذي يبعد
امتار عن القصر الرئاسي
هجوم حركه الشباب على فندق فيلاروسا
القريب
للقصر رئاسي الصومالي ياتي في سياق رد
الحركه على تعرضها للاغارات الجويه
ومعالك ميداليه ادت الى
فقدانها مناطق استراتيجيه تقع وسط الصومال
خاصه في ولايته هيرش
كذلك الغارات الجويه ايضا ادت الى مقتل
العشرات من حركه الشباب
لحركه شباب على هذه الاستهدافات لها ولكن
سؤال هو كيف تفسر هذا الخلق الامن الكبير
في قلب العاصمه مقديشه مع توجيه كل هذه
الضربات التي تتحدث عنها من قبل الحكومه
وتركيز عمليات منذ اشهر لمهاجمه واقع هذه
الحركه خارج العاصمه الصوماليه وفي
اماكنها واستطاعتها تنفيذ مثل هذا الهجوم
خلال هذه الفتره الزمنيه امتدت قرابه
اليوم قرب القصر الرئاسي
هذه العمليه اولا ليست هي الاولى من نوعها
بل كانت سابقا تذكرون ان الحركه نفذت
عمليه عسكريه داخل قصر الرئاسي ولكن ربما
ايضا ياتي هذا الحديث في في في عدم او في
عدم صعوبه يعني فصل بين همم تشكيلات
العسكريه لانه هناك همم مختلف تشكيلات
عسكريه منتشره في في العاصمه وبالتالي
الحركه هي همم تستخدم وسائل متنوعه للوصول
الى تلك الاهداف اضافه الى انها تستخدم
المال لك ذلك للوصول الى هذه الاهداف
الحساسه اضافه الى هناك ربما احيانا ضعف
التفتيش في النقاط التفتيش المحيطه
بالقاسيه الرئاسي وكذلك في المناطق الاخرى
فهذه العمليه ربما انا شخصيا لا استغلبها
لانها لماذا لان يبدو ان هناك همم الصعوبه
بطبيعه الاحوال تشمها تشمها جماعه تصادف
فيها هذه الحركه التي تصنفها ارهابيه ما
نوع الدعم المطلوب من قبل الحكومه
الصوماليه التي تطالب به المجتمع الدولي
امريكا
لمحدده والتي تؤدي الى مقتل بعض القيادات
الحركه ولكنها لا تؤدي الى كسر العظام
الحركه وبالتالي الرئيس الصومالي هو يعني
ما يقوله ويريد دعما شاملا من التحالف
الدولي خاصه من امريكا على قرار دعم
امريكا للعراق عندما قضت على داعش وكذلك
التحالف العربي في اليمن وبالتالي الرئيس
صومالي يبحث ويتحدث عن يطلب دعما حقيقيه
ان يؤدي الى تحرير جميع
الحركه وهذا لم يحدث حتى الان شكرا شكرا
لك يا عبد الرحمن سالك البحث والمحل
الاساسي حدثنا من مقديش
لاحقا انسان نتناولوا في فقره المتابعه
جردا لابرز العمليات في الصومال ونسال
ضيفنا عن دلالتها وسياقها الامني والسياسي
[موسيقى]
من المراجعه جدا ان يشهد مطلعه الاسبوع
سلسله ضربات الروسيه جديده هذا ما قالته
المتحدثه باسم القياده الجنوبيه للجيش
الاوكراني مشيره الى ظهوري سفينه صواريخ
روسيه في البحر الاسود وعلى واقع تحذير
الرئيس الاوكراني من وضع صعب جدا على
الجبهه يستمر القتال في دنيا شرقا وتنقل
روترز عن مصادر امريكيه مطلعه قولها ان
البنتاجون يدرس ارسال اسلحه مداها 150
كيلو مترا الى اوكرانيا تفاصيل المشهد
الميداني نستعرضها في التقرير الثاني
حل فصل الشتاء في اوكرانيا وبدا يفرد
ايقاعه على طرفي الحرب
استمرت المعارك على اكثر من محور لتحقيق
اكبر قدر من المكاسب الميدانيه قبل ان
يشتد البرد تبدو قوات الطرفين في سباق مع
الزمن فبعد اسبوع من الان ستنزل درجات
الحراره الى ناقص 10 تقول الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ان روسيا تعد لحمله جديده من
القصف على منشاتها الكهربائيه يتحدث عمده
كياب عن الاضرار التي لحقت بشبكه الكهرباء
ويقول ان النسبه 40% من التيار معطره تتهم
اوكرانيا روسيا باستخدام البرد السلاحا
وبفرده ظروف قاسيه على المدنيين وترد
روسيا بانها لا تستهدف الا المنشات التي
لها ارتباط بالجيش الاوكراني في هذه
الاجواء تواصل القوات الاوكرانيه اجلاء
المدنيين من مدينه خيرسون التي ساعدتها
مؤخرا تجري عمليات الاجلاء في ظروف صعبه
باحوال الجو ولان المدينه تتعرض بقصف من
مواقع القوات الروسيه التي انسحبت اليها
وراء نهر دنيبر تقول كيف ان لديها معلومات
بان القوات الروسيه تعد بعمليات قصف مكثفه
على خرص خلال الايام المقبله اما رئيس
تونس الموالي لروسيا فيتحدث عن نقد كيف
مقاتلين من الاحتياط من خلص الى دونيتسك
للمشاركه في المعارك في جبهتي لوجان قالت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها سدتها هجمات
عده وقتلت اكثر من 160 جندي الاوكرانيا
وارغمت القوات الاوكرانيه عن العوده الى
مواقع الاصليه في منطقه خاركيف ويستمر
الجدل بشان محطه بروج النوويه فقط روسيا
على لسان المتحدث باسم الكربلاند
سحابه من المحطه قال ان ذلك لم يحدث ولا
لم يحدث
بعد ان اعلنت السلطات اوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه في المحطه النوويه ستكون مرغمه
على الانسحاب امام الهجمات المضاده التي
تشنها القوات الاخرانيه في المنطقه يعني
في الكريم فكره الانسحاب في وقت تتحدث فيه
السلطات المواليه له عن حجر كياب اكثر من
700 جندي من القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه في
محيطولوجيا استعدادا لاقتحام لمحطه
النوويه في المقاطعه يستمر الكره اذن في
حربا لا يبدو انها ستضع اوزارها قريبا
ويبدو ان الاوكرانيين استسلموا لهذا
الاهتمام وبداوا يعدون العده لفصل شتاء
صعب يتوقعوا ان تزداد فيه قسوه الحرب في
بلد تنزل فيه درجات الحراره احيانا اذا
ناقص 20
في ظل استمرار القصف الروسي على مقاطعه
خيرسون واشتداد القتال بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه على طرفي نهر دنبرو
في المقاطعه يعني السكان من انعدام
الخدمات الاساسيه كالماء والكهرباء وتقول
السلطات الاوكرانيه انها تعمل على مدار
الساعه لاستعاده الخدمه
ما زالت الحرب تفرض سطوتها على خير سول
رغم انسحاب الروسي منها يتواصلوا القصف
ويشتد البرد وتنعدم خدمات الماء والكهرباء
هكذا صارت المدينه في زمن الحرب متعبه
منهكه
لانتشار خير صور من واقعها هذا انشات
السلطات الاوكرانيه نقاطا لتوزيع المياه
على من بقي من السكن
من الموت باعجوبه لكننا فقدنا الماء
والكهرباء وكل شيء
طوابير طويله تنتظر قصتها من الماء
بجد لتلبيتها
في مكان اخر تتجلى صوره اخرى ليوميات
الحرب مثل هذه الخيام تنتشر بكثره في عموم
المدينه اطلقت عليها السلطات تسميه خيام
الحقيقه وزودتها بمولدات الكهرباء لتسهيل
حياه الناس
اتت لشحن مصباحها عله يضيء ما خلفته عتمه
الحرب
لا املك الكهرباء في منزلي اريد الحصول
على اي بصيص امل من اجل اولادي نامل ان
يكون هناك حل كريم
بات كفاحا يوميا في خير سول
عزلت خير سول لمده طويله عن امدادات
الطاقه وفي ظل عراقي لتوفيرها للجميع
ناشدت السلطات السكان ضروره النزوح
الطبيعيه الى مناطق وسطي وغربي اوكرانيا
انسحب الرسوم من خيرسون اذا لكنهم تركوا
ورائهم اثار حب ثقيله حرب لا زال صداها
يسمع في الارجع الجزيره خير
[موسيقى]
اعلنت سلطاته مدينه اوروبيه
شمال غرب الصين تخفيفه اجراءات الاغلاق
المتعلقه
بمكافحه فيروس كورونا وتشمل تسهيلات
استئناف عمل السكك الحديديه وطيران المدني
والحافلات وسيارات الاجره تدريجيه تاتي
الخطوه بعد احتجاجات شعبيه في مدن صينيه
مختلفه على سياسه الاغلاقات المستمره في
البلاد منذ ظهور الفيروس قبل نحو ثلاث
سنوات في مدينتي
[تصفيق]
هذه
البؤره الاولى
وقد ضاق سكانها زرعا باجراءات الاغلاق
التي تفرضها السلطات الصينيه منذ نحو ثلاث
سنوات
ازال المحتاجون الحواجز القصديريه التي
تعزل مجمعات سكنيه باكملها رقعه
الاحتجاجات التاسعه لتصل الى العاصمه
اما المطالب فهي نفسها نعم للحريه لا
للاغلاقات
لكل شخص مطالبه بشان الاغلاق اعتقد انه من
الجيد توفير مساحه للتعبير والنقاش
والخروج بنتيجه طرد الجميع
سرعان ما تحولت المظاهرات السلميه الى
اشتباكات مع رجال الامن في شنغهاي انتهت
بالقاء القبض على عشرات المحتجين تحركات
شعبيه نادره في الصين لانهاء سياسه
الاغلاقات التي استمرت نحو ثلاث سنوات
دفعت السلطات المحليه في رموتشي الى تخفيف
بعض القيود واستنى في حركه المواصلات في
المدينه
تدريجيا سمحت السلطات في ارموتشي عاصمه
مقاطعه الشنجه باستئناف في عمل السكك
الحديديه والحافلات وغيرها من وسائل النقل
التي توقفت جراء الاغلاق الذي دام لاكثر
من 100 يوم بلديه العاصمه بيجين اكدت ايضا
العمل على تخفيف حده الاجراءات الاحترازيه
على الحياه اليوميه للمواطنين
لكبار السن والمرضى وضمان التشغيل الامن
للمرافق الاساسي بهد تقليدي تاثير الوباء
على عمل الناس وحياتهم الطبيعيه
رغم تخ
فيف اليتيم فان السلطات الصينيه تعاهدت
بالابقاء على سيا
سه حجه وفي ذلك معدله اصابه قياسيه
بالفيروس بلغت 40 الف حاله في اليوم
الواحد ارتفاع قد يغرق نظام الرعايه
الصحيه في البلاد في حال لم يتم احتوائه
سريعا حيث يوجد بالصين اكثر من 250 مليون
شخص فوق سن ال 60 شيماء جوي الجزيره
وفي ردود الفعل اعتبر المتحدث باسمه مجلس
الامن القومي التابع للبيت الابيض ان من
حق الناس وتظاهر في اي مكان من العالم بما
في ذلك الصين وقال المتحدث انه سيكون صعبا
على الصين القضاء على فيروس كورونا اذا
استمرت في تطبيق استراتيجيه صفر كوفيد
التي تعتمدها منذ تفشي الوباء
من جانبه وصف المتحدث باسم رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني اعتقال صحفيا في هيئه الاذاعه
البريطانيه خلال تغطياته الاحتجاجات ضد
الاغلاق في الصين وصفه بالصادم وغير
المقبول وقال المتحدث ان الحكومه
البريطانيه ستواصل اثاره موضوع حقوق
الانسان مع الحكومه الصينيه بشكل بناء
ومفيد لعلاقات البلدين حسب تعبيره
ينضم الينا من بيجين فيكتور جاو رئيس
الجمعيه الصينيه للدراسات الدوليه انضم
الينا من دوشم باي ديفيد سيدني نائب مساعد
وزير الدفاع الامريكي لشؤون الامن القومي
في اسيا سابقا مرحبا بكم وابدا معك الى
اداره تجاوزت الاحتجاجات في الصين مطالب
تخفيف القيود وانهاء الاغلاق الى
مطالب لتحمل شعارات سياسيه
الاحد فان الاحتجاجات حصلت في عده مدنه في
الصين حيث اعيش هنا ايضا
وكانت التركيز الاحتجاجات بشكل اساسي
يتمحور حول بعض الاجراءات المبالغه فيها
في تطبيق
الاغلاق وعمل عمليات الحجره ايضا وكان
هنالك بعض المحتاجين غير راضيين عن هذا
الامر هذا امر مفهوم لان جاء الان على وشك
ان تدخل في سنتها الرابعه وبدا الناس
صبر الناس بدا
هو ايضا الحكومه تحتاجه ان تقوم باجراء
تعديل لكن مهمه للاجراءات
القاسيه التي تبنتها وانا اعمل في نفس
الوقت على ان المحتاجين يدركون ان مساله
هذه السياسه سيا طافت قدم منعت همم
اصابه الملايين من الاشخاص وانقذت حياته
الابعاد سياسيه تطالب الحكومه بالمزيد
ايضا من فتح الحريات والتعبير عن الراي
الحريه الاكبر هو حريه العيش اذا ما خسرت
الحياه ستخسر اي حريه قد تتمتع بها لذلك
اعتقد ان المحتاجين عليهم ان يدركوا ان
هذه
السؤال الفلسفي مهم ان حقوق الانسان دائما
مهمه لكن الحق الاهانه وحق العيش والحياه
وهذا هو
حققته الصين
كبير في طريقه او باخرى على الرغم من انها
قد حققت هذا الامر بكلفه عاليه وقد تكون
بازعاج كبير للجميع
في كل الاحوال
وحاله الغضب القفز الى حاله الغضب السريع
من قبل المواطنين خلال الايام الثلاثه
التي شهدتها الاحتجاجات
برنامج تنزيل
تحدث عنها السيد جاب اولها هي عدم الرضا
حول تاثير القيود المتعلقه على حياتي
الناس والضرر الذي احدثته هذه القيود على
الاقتصاد وايضا دمرت مستوى العيش للناس
لكن فيما بالاضافه الى ذلك هنالك بعض
الشعارات التي قالت ان هنالك عدم الرضا
حول سياسه الحزب الشيوعي وعدم الرضا حول
سياسه الرئيس
تم اختياره مؤخرا من قبل الحزب لفتره
الرئاسيه الاخرى بتختلف اطول
ان الناس فلسطين لا يجب الاستماع الى
اصواتهم ومطالباتي الشعب الصيني
التي تتحدث عن همم ضروره وجود اصلاحات
سياسيه همم يعني امر اللافت همم جدا همم
كيف تفسر القفز الى مثل هذه الشعارات من
شعارات تطالب با انهاء حاله الاغلاق
واتباع سياسه صفر كوفد الى هذه الحموله
السياسيه الكبيره
لتقريري ما هي الاحتجاجات وما الامور التي
يبدو انه غير راضي عنها لكن حسب راي هنالك
حديث عن عده قضايا والان الامر يعود
للرئيس للحزب الشيوعي لاخذ قرار اذا ما
كان هنالك سيكون مرونه لتلبيه مطالب الناس
او ان يكون هنالك حمله تواجهها وقد تنتهي
بالالف فهذا وضعنا جديد للرئيس الشيك كان
هناك عده سنوات منذ حصوليا اخر مظاهرات
فلسطين بالتالي هذا الامر يمثل تحديا لهم
ايضا للحزب الشيوعي في الصين لرؤيتي كيفيه
ادارتهم لهذه الاحتجاجات سيد جاوب برايك
كيف ستدير الصينيه همم هذا الملف خاصه
بانه اتخذ منحا يعني لا يمكن انها لم تحسب
حساب له
بدايه لان الاحتجاجات حصلت بشكل اساسي في
ليله الاحد في عده مدن في الصين يوم امس
يوم الاثنين انا في حقيقه الامر كنت اتجول
في مدينه بيج ولم ارى اييي مؤشرات لتجمعات
او احتجاجات او مظاهرات على الاطلاق يوم
الاثنين هذا مؤشر قوي على ان المحتاجين
بغض النظر عن مكانه يحتاجون عنه الان
وكانهم هداوا وانا الحكومه قد تحدثت مع
المحتاجين وبعض الاشخاص الذين هم وراء هذه
الاحتجاجات واعتقد اننا نتحرك في الاتجاه
الصحيح في تهجئه الموقف
ومحاوله التواصل الى حلول حول هذه
البوابات القلق الحقيقيه التي كانت في
محور هذه الاحتجاجات لكن بالنسبه همم
ضوضاء سياسيه همم اخر انا اختلف معه اعتقد
ان ما تحتاجه تفصيل الان هو الاستقرار
الاستقرار من اجل المرور في هذه المرحله
الانتقاليه من طريقه تقليديه واا سياسه
كوبد او صفر كوبد الى مرونه الاكبر
بتاقلوا من اكبر من اجل ضماني ان الحياه
اليوميه للناس الاعتيادين والنشاطات
الاقتصاديه
ستتحرق بدلا من تاخيرها ويعاقتها هذه
نتيجه هذه الاجراءات
المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي تابعه
للبيت الابيض همم قال بان من حق الناس
التظاهر في اي مكان من العالم بما في ذلك
الصين كيف ترصد رد الفعل الامريكي على ما
جرى في الصين خلال الايام الثلاثه
اماكن
الامريكيه هو بيان واضح يبدو ان هناك امور
اخرى لعبه دوره كبيره في ما حصل في الصيفي
حقيقه الامر الكثير من الصينيين كانوا
يتابعون
كاس العالم في قطر
حياتنا اعتياديه وعندما يقارنون الامر في
السكره هنالك تاثير كبير على حياته
المواطنين العاديين في الصين هم لا يريدون
ان يكونوا مواطنين من الدرجه الثانيه شكرا
لكم
سعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي لشؤون الامن
القومي في اسيا سابقا واشكرك ايضا
دكتور رئيس الجمعيه الصينيه للدراسات
الدوليه شكرا لكم
نعود الى الهجوم على فندق في قلب العاصمه
الصوماليه بالقرب من القصر الرئاسي هل هو
الاول من نوعيه الاجابه لا بطبيعه الحال
لكن ما الذي حدث في الساعات قليل الماضيه
باستخدام اسلحه ومتفجرات هاجم مسلحون فندق
فيلا روز في مقديش الذي يرتديه مسؤولون
كبار وبرلمانيون واقعوا على بعد شوارع
قليله من مكاتب الرئيس الصومالي وتحدث
شهود انفجارات اعقبها اطلاق نار ويقول
شاهد عيان رايت عده سيارات عسكريه ما قوات
الخاصه تتجه الى الفندق طوقت المنطقه
ورايت اشخاصا يفرون وعلى موقعه الالكتروني
وصفا فندق
اكثر اماكن الاقامه امانا في مقديشه مع
اجهزه كشف عن المعادن وسور مرتفع وقبل
ساعات اعلن انتهاء الحصار لكن
حصار فندق فيلاروزا شهير ليس الاول من
نوعه فقد قتل ما لا يقل عن 21 نزلا في
فندق في مقديشو خلال حصار استمر 30 ساعه
في اغسطس الماضي حصار الفنادق والهجوم
عليها وقت حامها اثر اسئله حول كيفيه تمكن
المسلحين من بلوغ الوسط الاداري للعاصمه
الصوماليه الذي يحظى بحمايه مشدده من دون
ان يرصدهم احد فعلى طرقات المؤديه الى
المنطقه هناك نقاط تفتيش كما تضم المنطقه
ايضا مركز اعتقال للمشتبهي بضلوعهم في
اعمال عنف يخضع لاشراف الاستخبارات
الصوماليه
وجاء هجوم مقديشو بعد يومين من عمليه
للجيش الصومالي في وسط البلاد قتل فيها ما
لا يقل عن 100 من مسلحين حركه الشباب بحسب
القوات المسلحه الصوماليه وياتي الهجوم
الجديد ايضا في وقت قرر فيه رئيس الصومالي
حسن شيخ محمود المنتخب في ما يويار الماضي
سنما سماها حرب شامله على حركه الشباب
وحققت القوات الحكوميه الصوماليه بعض
المكاسب في المعارك الميدانيه في اطار
الحمله العسكريه على حركات الشباب خلال
الاشهر الثلاثاء الماضيه هذه الحمله على
مسلحي حركات الشباب تاتي بدعم من جماعات
المسلحه قبليه وفي بعض الاحيان من قوات
الاتحاد الافريقي وغارت جويه امريكيه لكن
الهجامات تتصاعد فوفقا للامم المتحده قتل
ما لا يقل عن
613 مدنيه وجرح
948 في اعمال عنفا في هذا العام الج جماعه
مسوبه الى حركات الشباب وهذه الارقام هي
الاعلى منذ عام 2017
وشهدت ارتفاعا باكثر من 30% مقارنه بالعام
الماضي بالرغم من الحمله على حركه الشباب
نشير الى ان حركه شباب المجاهدين التي
اعلنت مسؤوليتها عن الهجوم الاخير وهجمات
اخرى تحاول الاطاحه بالحكومه المركزيه
الصوماليه منذ 15 عاما
للمزيد حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
لندن
وهو رئيس تحرير مجله افريقيا
والخبير المختص بالشؤون الافريقيه مرحبا
بك سيد همم
بدايه ما تفسير ما يجري في العاصمه
الصوماليه
خصوصا استهداف اماكن تعد قلب العاصمه التي
من المفروض ان يكون الاكل
ديسباسيتو
التي تمكن فيها عناصر حركه الشباب من
اختراق هذه المناطق في مكاديشا يبدولي
وكان لديهم بعض الاشخاص الذين يعملون من
داخل تلك الاماكن هذا الامر مكنهم من
النفاذي عبر التفحص الامني وبالتالي شد
تلك الهجمات
عن امكانيه القوات الصوماليه من تطويق هذه
الظاهره خلال هذه الاشهر المتواصله من
العمليات التي تشرينها بمساعده من
المسلحين قبليين ولاتحاد الافريقي وايضا
القوات الامريكيه
تحميل
وصول الرئيس الحالي في شهر مايو فان
الرئيس محمود حقيقه قبل ان يصبح رئيسا
جعل من اهدافه ان يقضي على حركه الشباب
وهذا ما كان يقوم به بمساعده بعض العناصر
من القبائل بالتالي
فان لها جمال
الشباب ضد الشباب
منذ تولي الحكومه امم مسؤولياتها في هذه
السنه وهنا والسؤال الى اين سيذهب المشهد
الامني في الصومال مع كل هذه المعطيات
عليه لان
الحكومه وكل ما زادت قوه هجمه الحكومه على
حركه الشباب كلما
همم
زادت قوه انتقام حركه الشباب لكن اعتقد
بجهود قوه الحكومه ولا قبائل وايضا قوات
الاتحاد الافريقي وايضا بمساعده الولايات
المتحده اعتقد ان حركه شباب سيتم ستلحق
بها الهزيمه لكن ليس في المستقبل القريب
لكن على المستوى على البدل بعيده اعتقد ان
الهزيمه ستكون من نصيب حركه الشباب هل ترى
بان المقربه العسكريه هي الانجح
النهارده اسود مباشر
الان لكن اعتقد ان حركه الشباب ليست مستعد
لانخراط في حوار مع الحكومه من اجل توصلي
الى حل ودي هذه الحكومه الحاليه ايضا
هنا فيها ايضا اعضاء من حركه الشباب
بالتالي فان هذا
الامر قد يعطينا طباعا عن موقف هذه
الحكومه من الحركه لكن يبدو لي ان حركه
الشباب قد تكون مستعده بالتالي مع للحوار
مع الحكومه لكن ليس الان من لندن جونسون
اوف فاير رئيس تحرير مجله افريقيا والخبير
المختص بشؤون الافريقيه شكرا لك
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه وقبل
الجوله الرياضيه يوميات المونديال اليكم
موجزا باهم الانباء كشف تركيا
وعلانات وزاره الدفاع التركيه تحديدا 14
عنصرا نمسحي حزب العمال الكرد الثاني
ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
قال الرئيس التركي ان بلاده صوت واصل
عملياتها العسكريه حتى القضاء على جميع
التنظيمات الارهابيه واضاف في كلمه القاها
عقب اجتماعا للحكومه التركيه انه لم يعد
مقبولا تقديم بعض الدول الغربيه الداعم
لتنظيمات الارهابيه التي تستهدف الاراضيه
التركيه
اعلنت الشرطه الصوماليه انتهاء هجوم
مسلحيه حركات الشباب على فندق فيلاروسا في
العاصمه مقديشو واضافت الشرطه ان خمسه عشر
شخصا قتلوا بينهم المهاجمون السته ورجل
امن صومالي وطالب الرئيس الصومالي المجتمع
الدولي بدعم حكومه فيما سماها الحرب على
الارهاب
قالت البحريه الاوكرانيه ان روسيا حشدت 11
سفينه حربيه في البحر الاسود وحضر رئيس
الاوكراني من تصعيد روسيا هجماتها على
محطات الطاقه ودعا للاستعداد لشتاء قاسم
وقارس في البلاد
قالت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه انها تدرس
ارسال اسلحه مداها 150 كيلومترا الى
اوكرانيا من جانبه قال الامين العام لحلفي
شمال الاطلسيه في السلطه البرج انه لا
يمكن ترك الرئيس الروسي بلادي مركوت يعني
ينتصر في حربه على اوكرانيا
اعلنت السلطات مدينه ارومانسيه عاصمه
مقاطعه تشينج يانغ تخفيفه اجراءات الاغلاق
المتعلقه بمكافحه فيروس كورونا تعطي
الخطوه بعد احتجاجات شعبيه في مدن صينيه
على اجراءات الاغلاق المستمر من ظهور
الفايروس قبل نحوي 3 سنوات في مدينه وهان
ودعت الامم المتحده بجين لاحترام معايير
حقوق الانسان الدوليه
اعتبر المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
التابعه للبيت الابيض انا من حق الناس
التظاهر في اي مكان من العالم بما في ذلك
الصين بدورها اكد المتحدث وباسم رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ان الحكومه البريطانيه
صوت واصل اثاره موضوع حقوق الانسان مع
الحكومه الصينيه بشكل بناء ومفيد لعلاقات
البلدين
لذلك ينتهي حصاد الليله شكرا على المتابعه
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]